Ezekiel Elliott expected to be the first
running back taken in Thursday night's
draft and the former Ohio State running
back joins us now
first of all Z or Z Q I should say what
is what is the nickname you go boy Oh
couple nicknames is there Zeke
because eazy-e the hero of a half sir I
got a couple yeah things these come more
I like easy I like easy it's old-school
to me yeah okay okay yeah
but I don't know if you change your
nickname when you go into the NFL but
you know easy straight out of the
backfield like straight out of Compton
you're straight out of the backfield
eazy-e what do you think the trade
market where will you be on draft night
I will be a saccade I like that okay if
I said to you tell me the team you think
is in love with you would you be able to
tell me like truly fallen in love with
you do you have one of those teams
thanks Ricardo bears they're in love
with you I think they are is Dallas in
love with you know if I have to ask them
easy then they're not in love with you
so Chicago's in love with you are the
Giants in love with you okay I got
another team that's in love with you
the Miami Dolphins are in love with you
I was thinking there too when did it
change when we weren't drafting running
but used to be drafted running backs hi
and then Todd Gurley last year gets
drafted and then becomes the Rookie of
the Year but what why is it teams are
shying away from drafting running backs
in the top ten
come out come out first thing I got I
got a I got a bone to pick with McLovin
you know I heard you you're devaluing me
I heard you got me pretty low you're my
dress and I mean so
probable he's not McLovin doesn't even
have you in his top ten well Wow look
love Annette why is that mclovin Wow
well here's the deal for years I said
you can't draft a running back in the
top ten and can I change my whole
philosophy just because you convinced me
that you are an exception well because
I've always lowered running backs now
are you the exception but why why can't
you drive in the top ten you didn't give
me any reason you know what my reason
just these teams don't do it so I
figured they'll be there now your
probably won't be there but usually you
can get a you get a Pro Bowl or a little
later
I like a 59-yard guy now Ezekiel you
should understand that mclovin ever
played football but I do wear a half
shirt was a while that's a nobody yes as
he can I wouldn't do that he sleep over
my mark dad in fact it might help you
but also Ezekiel he said yesterday we
got into this discussion that Leonard
fournette will have a better NFL career
than you and I said that's not the case
because you do more things than Leonard
fournette this is the kind of
discussions we get in on this program so
I had your back yesterday and here's
McLovin taking Leonard fournette you
know I think I think when it comes I
think I think people they get more
enamored by you know big flashy runs but
footballs not less failure a flashy game
you know is about consistency you know
it's about going out there cause it's a
performer every set and I think that's
what I do I think that's what separates
me from from other players I think every
play you know I give a consistent effort
you know persistent excellent well who
are you like is there somebody that you
sort of modeled your game after I'm
Marshall Faulk
you know a guy the other side was guy
that's the guy I was growing up you know
that was a guy I kind of mimicked my
game master you know just kind of I take
pride in being a jack-of-all-trades
I take pride and I don't think
the play I don't think I have a weakness
on the field I think that you know I've
done a great job you know becoming good
at everything you know so I think that's
what separates me you know I'm I'm I'm a
great pass catcher I mean I'm I'm
excellent and pass pass protection which
is the most important thing you can't
play you can't play you can't get on the
field if you're not gonna go take that
that franchise quarterback and I might
become I'm with great hair fighting
outside right did
how many Ohio State players get drafted
in the first round this year yeah
so you Bosa dinner as Cardale Jones
getting drafted first round oh who else
gets drafted first job yeah
Neal I get shafted Taylor Decker
isn't there could be six Ohio State
players first out now Cardale I saw
where people said he could move up you
know pretty hot he's starting to move up
a little bit higher but they had him
down third or fourth round why is that
I'm not exactly sure but honestly my
visit contains uh I heard a lot of
coaches talked very highly of him and a
lot of coaches really like cardio I
noticed that you're not afraid to tug on
Jim Harbaugh's cape you know coach with
Michigan what would you say if you saw
Harbaugh on the street Wow would you
just point to the scoreboard or
something what you wouldn't say a word
to him
yeah it's probably smart to do that but
Harbaugh I love that I love the the fact
that you stirred this rivalry up a
little bit though it's
wait is there a fire going on there
what's going on behind you oh I'm on
fire not far away from you
Ezekiel's joining us on behalf of the
new Old Spice hardest-working collection
performance lineup you want to tell us
more about that
no Old Spice is always performed but you
know they have a new collection called
the hardest-working collection and is
the strongest almost price better you
know you know all spices it's perfect
for for us hard-working athletes you
know we great antidepressant together
and body losses and you know that's when
some some great some grace emails and I
would say my favorite set its prior to
last and legend you might actually use
it this morning before I got on the
phone what if there was this a Wolverine
sent would you not wear it
would you rather build it out deodorant
than the Wolverine sent is there is
there one that smells like Buckeyes yeah
of course it is hey a good luck for more
information on you can go to Old Spice
calm and good luck on draft night
McLovin did you change your mont draft
good news Ezekiel you've moved up to
number four you go to Dallas in my mock
draft
Thank You zekiel all right that's ozq
Elliot the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience